JUEZ MOLLER: Hoy en día, las partes procesales
JUEZ MOLLER: dentro del proceso penal seguido por el Ministerio público contra Néstor Limachi, Condori.
JUEZ MOLLER: para la presente audiencia para considerar la aplicación de sanciones alternativas
JUEZ MOLLER: se han cumplido con las notificaciones correspondientes.
JUEZ MOLLER: No está conectado virtualmente a la representante. Está conectado virtualmente al representante de trifulca, la doctora Tania Grecia, Calizaya Padilla.
JUEZ MOLLER: el acusado Néstor Limache condori no está conectado virtualmente tampoco su abogado, el doctor Morales aguaya
JUEZ MOLLER: si no hay mayor observación por parte del ministerio público. Voy a disponer la suspensión de esta audiencia a
JUEZ MOLLER: debiendo el impetrante, solicitar nuevo día y hora para considerar
JUEZ MOLLER: la aplicación de sanciones alternativas. Estamos de acuerdo, señora fiscal, ¿alguna observación.
MIN. PUB Tania Grecia Callisaya: Ninguna autoridad.
JUEZ MOLLER: Bien, no habiendo nada más que considerar, se da por suspendida la audiencia. ¡buen día.